today I'm gonna talk about webassembly
and many of you may not even heard of
that here there's like what what is web
assembly so I'm gonna answer some of
those things but first I just want to
make a little statement and that's I
really feel that we're on the brink of a
revolution and it's early right it's
very early in the revolution but I feel
like web assembly is going to completely
change how we think of web apps and what
a web app is capable of doing completely
change it and maybe a couple years out
but we're on the brink so as Gerard said
my name is J Phelps and I'm an engineer
over at Netflix and I the web assembly
is important to me because I'm a big
compiler nut so I like to work on
compilers in my free time and when I
first learned about web assembly I tried
to get involved as much as I can you
know obviously I still have my full-time
job but I wanted to to express some of
my excitement and passion and to the
rest of the community because I noticed
that a large number of people whenever I
talk to someone about web assembly
they'd say you know I've heard of it
like on Twitter or something like that
but I really don't know what it is like
I so you know and people are always
usually excited so what is web assembly
well for one it's also known as wasum
which is an abbreviation web assembly
ASM is usually the abbreviation for
assembly and it's an efficient low-level
bytecode for the web and that's that's a
cool catchphrase but what does it really
mean what does it mean when I say
efficient when I say efficient I mean
that it's fast to load and execute and
when I say load I mean it's fast you
transport the the compiled files over
the Internet to the person's browser and
then it's also fast to parse those
compiled files because this they run
inside a virtual machine and once it's
done parsing it it is still fast to
execute and it's it's efficient and fast
primarily because it is a low-level
bytecode and if you're not familiar with
the term
code this is an example of one of the
webassembly
opera using the upper operands who's
gonna be operators instructions I guess
is a more familiar term for it and this
is a hexadecimal so this is one byte so
because as human beings don't usually
read binary at least I know I don't that
often it's it's an web assemblies
intended as a compilation target right
so you will write in some other
programming language like C C++ rust and
possibly some other ones that I'll talk
about and then you compile that ahead of
time to web assembly and then you shift
those web assembly files to your browser
so here's an example if you're not
familiar with C or C++ I think it's
fairly straightforward you know
basically you can just ignore the types
the end stuff and it's pretty much
exactly like JavaScript this is for
generating a factorial and with web
assembly that C code equals basically
this binary code this bytecode right and
we're going to come back to this so
don't worry if this is a little Lego
what's going on web assembly is also
designed to be safe and portable and
safe and portable what I mean by that is
it's just in the same way as JavaScript
is right you don't have to deal with
memory overflow exploits and things like
that and it's portable so it'll run in
any browser that supports web assembly
just like JavaScript runs in all of
these browsers because it kind of is the
same goal of what Java intended to do
and and job has been really successful
at this on the server side not but not
nearly as much on the web side with like
the Java applet stuff so there's a
really great quote from Ben Smith who's
on the chrome team and he said that it
that web assembly is the shortcut to
your JavaScript JavaScript optimizer and
it's actually very true it's not it's
he's it's not a metaphor in all the
browsers that have implemented web
assembly they literally use the existing
virtual machine they have because it's
been hardened over the years and it's
very fast and very powerful but because
web assembly is is a strictly tight
bytecode it can go straight to the
optimizer and doesn't need to do all
these intermediary just-in-time
compilation so you might be thinking if
it is this going to kill JavaScript then
right if this is a short if this is a
shortcut to that optimizer why wouldn't
why would I use JavaScript then I can
get faster performance of that and if
you ask the core team of Chrome or
Mozilla or any of those in there they're
gonna tell you nope this is not intended
to kill JavaScript and they're right
it's not that's not the intent and it it
probably won't kill JavaScript but I am
gonna to make a little prediction and
I'm gonna say maybe someday it might not
entirely kill JavaScript but it's gonna
change the way we write our Reb apps
enough that you may end up writing
majority of your app in a totally
different language maybe even a language
this is a bet that doesn't even exist
today so the other question you might
ask is well then will we be compiling
our JavaScript to web assembly right if
we can shortcut to that to that
optimizer why wouldn't we just compile
it well that's not really feasible
because javascript is extremely dynamic
extremely dynamic and sometimes we
forget because we try and use best
practices to not use some of those
dynamic features but technically there
are a lot of really really dynamic
things that you can do with JavaScript
that are pretty complex and so to have
that compilation you'd have a fairly
large runtime and in many cases you'd
actually have to ship almost a virtual
machine yourself so we're talking
several megabytes of code just to be
able to run the code that your
application contains now as the web
sembly gets further and further along
and adds additional features this
becomes less of a valid argument but as
of now in in the future it does not
appear that javascript is going anywhere
it's a great language for its intent but
webassembly just basically opens up new
possibilities that weren't really
feasible today so it would it would
almost be slower if you could try to
compile JavaScript to webassembly it's
just it doesn't miss doesn't make sense
so
it's still missing things the MVP or the
v1 of webassembly
is best suited and was kind of designed
around the C++ in or rust use case and
why is that
well since webassembly is very low-level
it's a very low-level language it makes
sense that programming languages that
are basically just one step above an
assembly language would be easier to
compile to that right so languages like
C++ and rust
they don't have garbage collection they
use different techniques like cincy you
might use normal malloc just manual
memory management in C++ if you're using
the new versions you might use smart
pointers or write or auto and things
like that in rust they they use a
totally different paradigm that's a
that's a really great talk in its own
actually but these languages don't use
garbage collection so they don't need
all this complicated runtime stuff to
keep track of that stuff so web assembly
is a really natural target for them and
on top of that these languages aren't
really a hundred percent designed or
intended to you have to call into
complex JavaScript things like mutating
the Dom like it doesn't really make a
whole lot of sense to build your entire
HTML app in C++ because C++ was not
designed around that use case certainly
you can do it but more often than not
when people are writing these C++ or
Russ things they're usually going to
target things like WebGL and or they're
going to be more library specific like
imagine in the future being able to
write your own json.parse utility that
was able to parse 64-bit integers like
those type of things are really great
use cases for these these low level
systems languages but other languages I
think I'm really confident I don't just
think I'm very confident that other
languages will be very popular in
webassembly very soon and one example of
that is turbo script and I don't know if
turbo scripts going to be popular but I
think that it really shows that you can
you can have your cake in a lot of ways
and eat it too and let me just show you
a little snippet of turbo script I can
guarantee no one here has probably ever
even heard of this but what does this
look like to you
thank you yeah typescript this looks
like typescript right and and if it if
it didn't say float32
and if you didn't say delete position at
the bottom you might think this was
typescript because it really turbo
script was designed to basically make
the typescript programmer or the
JavaScript programmer right at home but
guess what this compiles to web assembly
now before you get too excited because
web assembly doesn't have a garbage
collector yet you have to manually
manage your memory so every time you new
up an object it's basically calling
malloc if you're familiar with the
low-level stuff if you're not it's okay
it's creating a new instance of that
object when you call new and then if you
you have to manually call delete to free
up that memory if you don't call delete
that memory just gets leaked and you
especially if you lose a reference to
that and you get then you can never
delete it and the memories just leaked
so but when you're doing things like
libraries like let's say you're making a
utility functions that do some sort of
mathematical computation being able to
man you're managing your own memory is
really not that actually that big a deal
people are very used to that when you're
writing in languages like this or or in
fact you may not even need to allocate
on the heap you may be able to just use
the stack and you and that just
basically means you don't have to call
new you just create objects that will
just automatically be claimed reclaimed
when the current function returns so I
think these type of things really show
that brand-new languages I think will be
designed specific for the web use case
like I just heard and I haven't
confirmed this but I heard it like two
days ago someone here in the audience
told me this that Elm which is a
programming language very much based on
Haskell the Elm is designed specifically
for the web and right now it target's
JavaScript but they have recently
decided to start looking at the future
of trap Eiling to webassembly I don't
think they're gonna be able to do it any
time super soon because of memory
management stuff but we'll get to them
so win-win should wouldn't like target
webassembly
what kind of use cases is it best for
well right now in the v1 they're really
trying to focus on these heavily CPU
bound computations things that deal with
math where you're just using number
maybe 32-bit 64-bit or any kind of
numbers you're doing some sort of
computation webassembly really shines
with that and the most common thing
you'd say engineers think of when they
think of numbers is games at least if
you've ever written a game
there's tons of pixel stuff and it's a
lot of these are going to be heavily
OpenGL and so you can write your app in
C++ or rust your game using the OpenGL
bindings that you're very used to and
compile that to web assembly and it will
run in a browser and I want to show you
a little quick demo see if it plays
please play play oh it's being really
slow
oh no it's being jittery oh well that's
okay I think you can get the idea that
this is this is an example this is
actually running in Firefox the latest
version of Firefox without any flags
didn't have to enable anything I just
went to this website and this runs and I
can move around on my keyboard and
there's a whole bunch of other demos
that are that really show off that even
though webassembly is brand new you can
already do things this is running the
Unreal Engine for those of you familiar
so pretty exciting stuff but most of you
probably don't write games I don't write
games so the the game stuff is not super
attractive to me as an engineer but the
other use cases are coming sooner than
you'd might think right so you'll likely
compiling webassembly or excuse me
consuming webassembly binaries very soon
even if you're not actually writing code
that compiles to it you probably you'll
start to see web compiled projects and
libraries showing up on npm so keep keep
a lookout for that even if you're not
interested in in web assembly today so
let's circle back a little bit what was
that what's a binary stuff that I showed
before I write I had that factorial and
then I I showed that it got converted to
this binary representation well think
well what the heck is that well I I know
like me when I when I first saw binary
years ago like I'm just like
don't want to look at this this is
actually a hexadecimal of binary but
crazy stuff right it can be really
intimidating when you start looking at
binary thinking about oh do I have to
deal with this oh I I just don't want to
deal with it but the pro tip I'm gonna
give you is don't worry about it like if
it's there's tooling already today
around this where you don't need to
really worry about that you can
certainly if you want to if you nerd out
on that pull more power to you and
actually hit me up on Twitter cuz cuz I
want to nerd out on that too but for the
most part you unless you're implementing
your own compiler you don't necessarily
need to know a whole lot about binary so
there's a textual representation of web
assembly that's available so it's test
the text is going to be to the rescue so
and this is this is what that factorial
function looks like in web assembly in
the textual representation of it and
this is text right so you can read text
presumably
but you may not right now understand
what this means you may not understand
the actual semantics of that but let's
let's let's dive into this a little bit
let's learn the fundamentals of web
assembly so we can try and demystify
this text when you see this because this
is the text you're gonna see like if you
have if you ship a web assembly module
to the browser and you maybe set the
debugger up or you pause on exception
that's the textual representation you're
going to see so web assembly is a stack
machine language and that that's really
important to understand if you're going
to be actually trying to debug web
assembly itself now if you never debug
web assembly for some reason then you
don't even know that but if you are
debugging web assembly it's important to
know that so you might be asking next
well what the heck is a stack machine
like if I have to know this what is it J
well let's first cover a stack many of
you may not already know what this is
but I really want to make sure you
completely understand what a stack is a
stack is a data structure that basically
has two operations you can push things
on to the stack or you can pop things
off the sack let's take a look at what
that might look like
with a with a visual stack we've got our
stack here and let's say we've got an
item now what we want to do is we want
to take that
and push it onto the stack so over there
it goes now we get another item we want
to push that onto the stack and it goes
on top and that's an important
distinction it goes on top doesn't go on
bottom it doesn't go in and in some
random order when you push things on to
the stack it's always on top well push
one one more for good measure and then
there was the one more operation there
was the pop so if I'm popping something
off a stack of course we're gonna take
the top thing we're not gonna go
randomly we're not gonna go in the
bottom we're gonna pop that top thing
off the second and likewise when we
continue to pop pop it it off popping it
off and there we go now we've got an
empty stack so this is this pattern of
pushing and popping on a stack is called
last in first out order so that's
important I hope that helps fully
understand what a stack is and if we
want to apply this to the stack machine
it's a stack in which the items that are
on the stack are our instructions so
these instructions run and evaluate and
they push and pop values on this stack
and you may already be familiar with it
with a one form of stack like a call
stack for example and each time you call
a function you're putting that function
on the stack it executes a bunch of
things and then the call stack returns
it pops all of those things off of the
stack so let's let's look at some web
assembly this is not scary I hope so
let's let's first are very simply this
is not web assembly but this is this is
the very basic 1+2 right and in almost
every language this is how you do it
unless here in Haskell but this is what
the web assembly example or CD the web
assembly for the add operation looks
like this is called a mnemonic so on the
Left we have a textual representation of
that and on the right we have the actual
binary opto now you don't need a memory
that memorize the binary opto
again textual representation leaning
heavily on that so back to our one plus
two
this is what the code looks like to add
one plus two we've got a constant of one
it's a 32-bit integer a Const of two and
we're gonna add those two things
together so let's go back to our stack
visualization cost of one that pushes
the one on to the stack a cost of two we
push a two onto the stack and then we're
going to push at we're gonna we're gonna
execute add and what add does is it's
kind of like a function call in its it's
actually an instruction but you can
think of it kind of like a function call
that the computer itself will run and it
takes basically two arguments and how it
takes those arguments is it's going to
take the top two items and it's going to
take those off the stack it's gonna add
those together which is three and then
it'll put that back on the stack and and
replace those two values so now we have
the number three on the stack and so
from here the next instruction might be
pushing or might be dropping it off the
stack like you don't care about it like
return void or you may be logging this
out or something like that yeah here's
it here's a great example like like if
if you have a log function this is how
you do it you'd add the two numbers
together and then you you call the log
function so call is going to receive the
result of add we've got a stack of
instructions right and this I think is
is is fairly easy to understand and it
does take a little bit to get used to
the actual output which you'll see here
that which is that the compilers usually
apply lots of Optus optimizations so
even though you you wrote certain code
the actual output may not be what you
expect it to be and I'm not going to
show some really complicated examples
because I don't want to I mean it's just
gonna confuse you so what's the point
but like I can show you like a trivial
one like a really trivial one ship for
this example I don't know of any
compiler that does that any native
compiler that's not going to just do
this right like it knows statically at
compile time that one plus two equals
three so it's just going to convert that
to three and most compilers are going to
be even more clever they're going
look at what log does and if it can if
it has the definition if it's statically
linked it's gonna try and inline that
definition so that you don't have to pay
the cost of a function call because it
statically knows it so optimizations can
make things a little tricky but there's
another thing we can do and then that's
most of the web assembly tooling
supports an abstract an abstract syntax
tree representation of web assembly we
were looking at the stack based
representation but there's another
alternative representation that is an
abstract syntax tree now it's still
gonna be evaluated as a stack machine
but it's represented in a way that's
more human-friendly
and going back to our 1 + 2 add them
together and then call log this is stack
machine and this is abstract syntax tree
version of it and you'll notice that it
at first it can may be a little
confusing but these are called s
expressions and some of you I'm trying
to see if anyone is smiling no it looks
a lot like Lisp right I don't know if
any of you've done lists but yeah it
looks like listen why does it look like
Lisp because Lisp invented s expression
60 years ago so and Lisp excuse me s
expressions are used primarily because
they're dead simple to understand
because there's very little syntactic
sugar and they're extremely easy to
parse so all the tooling can can parse
it very easily and compile it but you
can see here that we've changed it so
instead of I'm going to jump back here
instead of having the stack of
instructions
we've instead got an AST so we can see
that we call add with the two arguments
and then call with it with the one
argument which is the result of the
adding and very often this is what
you'll see a lot of people use when
they're writing tests or when you're
using all these toolings
just because it's once once you get a
function of a decent-size things just
get really out of hand because sometimes
what will happen is you'll have a ton of
instructions and you'll have like one
instruction at the very top like it's
some constant or getting some local
varial or something that doesn't get
used until like the way bottom of the
stack is because that's how you have to
like programming and stack machines can
get a little little confusing and hairy
so you may be thinking why not source
right well source maps are coming soon
there they are not currently supported
by any browser because there isn't a
specification for it but it is on their
to-do list and probably soon ish I know
there hasn't been a lot of talk about it
lately like there was a lot in 2015 and
a little bit in 2016
lately they've kind of been prioritizing
other things but source map is coming
eventually so if you compile let's say
let's pie on the sky idea let's say Elm
in in a couple years is compiling to web
assembly you if you set a breakpoint
just like your Babel or typescript
translation or set a breakpoint you'll
see your elm code instead of seeing web
assembly so that's the goal so the next
thing is if this is exciting to you you
might be asking how do I get started
what do I do
how do I learn more about web assembly
if you want to know how the low-level
stuff works like more learn more about
actual web assembly there's a tool
called the web assembly Explorer this is
a hugely underrated tool like very few
people have tweeted this very few people
I know use this but it's so underrated
because was a guy at Mozilla maintains
this and basically on the left you can
type C++ or C and there's a whole bunch
of different versions of that and then
compile that and see the web assembly
text format and the Firefox x86 assembly
and you can also see LLVM ir if you
don't know what that is don't worry
about it but if you do is this thing is
amazing you can see exactly in in real
time what your code is actually going to
do in Firefox incredible tool and an
really invaluable fir for quickly
learning well what what happens when I
do this or in what happens when I do
that and you could find it here I'm
gonna post my slides so that you don't
have to frantically write this down or
I'll tweet this later actually I think
I'll tweet this later if you don't care
really about like web assembly itself
like you care about using web assembly
but learning web assembly stuff you
don't care about that the first thing
you're gonna want to do is go to web
assembly org and why is because they
they have it is really early but they
have right now some of the best
documentation for getting started with
it what you're going to end up probably
using is
they called em script in which is a
project that's been around for a number
of years but it's previous or it's its
goal up until now has been primarily
targeted towards compiling C and C++ to
JavaScript using a s MJS and if you
don't know what that is don't worry
about it but it's it's being adapted
because of the tooling is so great it's
being adapted to also suit the
webassembly purpose so it actually uses
LLVM and it's it's a basically just
another back-end to it and this is how
you would compile your c file your c or
c++ to web assembly and you get an
executable app dot HTML that will load
up the web assembly or you can also
target just a regular wasum file if you
don't want the HTML so I'm not gonna go
too much into this because I personally
find the tutorial things where like
someone's just like showing you
basically what the getting started would
do kind of boring because you're not all
you know able to do it right now so
you'll probably forget but the web
assembly org has has an excellent just
play-by-play of what you need to install
and I'll admit that I'm gonna skip ahead
just a little bit one slide I'll admit
that it is a little hairy right now when
you're using the description stuff but
webpack support is coming they are they
just submitted a grant proposal to the
Mozilla Foundation to try and get more
funding to try and hire more people get
into incentivize more people to
contribute to this so that they can add
support for web assembly in web pack and
not just being able to like link
different modules together like calling
you know a web assembly module from your
JavaScript but also imagine a C++ a rust
loader when other languages like turbo
script and elm and all these other
languages compile to it
imagine these loaders and so you don't
even need to set up all this other extra
tooling you can just import it like you
import your less files or your CSS or
whatnot that's the dream and the goal
that we're striving to but we do need
more people that are using this one of
the problems we have right now is it's
it's out in Firefox in Chrome but really
there's just not a whole lot of people
even playing with it not a whole lot of
people experimenting with it there's
they're the companies that are doing it
our play are doing it a lot like they're
making really big bets on it especially
than in the gaming industry they're
making really big bets but other use
cases we need people
to kind of you know experiment in their
free time and and try and discover the
growing pains and suggests where people
who volunteer their time to work on
these things should be focusing our
efforts so and that that leads me into
what's missing
where should we would should the
specification authors and community
members like myself I'm a community
member and a spec author but where
should we be focusing our efforts what's
well one thing that's missing is direct
access to the web ap is right now in web
assembly you have to call to JavaScript
to make any kind of meaningful side
effect actually any side effect at all
really so if you want to console.log you
have to call to javascript to do that
that's a great a great really easy
foreign function interface but you still
have to call into javascript of that and
that incurs a cost penalty and it's it's
just not as great because then you need
to actually include javascript to
basically shim those things but that's
that's not always going to be the case
they definitely plan to provide web api
s2m assembly so that you could ship a
web assembly file without any JavaScript
whatsoever but that's in the works it's
still a TBD this one I've already
mentioned garbage collection web
assembly right now is primarily only for
manual managed languages now you could
ship your own garbage collector but it
would be a little complicated because
you can't inspect the actual stack right
now but you could do it but it also that
your garbage collector will probably be
father rather large you know at least a
megabyte probably more you probably make
like a simple thing but isn't really
it's like a garbage collection like like
reference counting or something like arc
from a swift if you're familiar with
that but garbage collection is really
going to be necessary for better
interrupts with JavaScript so what
happens if I if I call a function from
JavaScript and it returns from web
assembly I call a function from
JavaScript it returns an HTML node or
something like that there's no way to
represent that in grab assembly right
now because if we gave them an opaque
reference to that element they we now
don't have a way to keep track of who
has a reference to it I could pass it
around inside my web assembly
and JavaScript would have no idea so it
would have to leak that memory so
interrupts with garbage collection is
gonna be super important multi-threading
this actually seems like one of the most
likely to come next I'm not gonna make
that promise but it from my readings and
the talks on the the tickets it sounds
like this is this is heavily being
designed right now this multi-threading
stuff and it sounds likely that web
assembly is going to get really close to
native threads like a very similar
threading model to normal C++ style P
threads so for me that's really exciting
because up until that point like with
JavaScript we only have web workers and
it's really very gimped like there's
only very very specific use cases for
webOS m/r for web workers and having
real threads is really gonna open up for
a lot of things now it's also gonna pop
for a lot of abuse so they're still
gonna do things like preventing you or
very likely to do things like preventing
you from blocking on the main thread so
keep that in mind and there's there's a
lot more that isn't isn't ideal in
webassembly for all these other
languages right for for C++ and rust
it's working fairly well but all these
other possible languages even things
like Oh camel they will be great in the
future but right now they're not ideal
for web assembly so the revolution is
just beginning with web assembly I think
that in in five max ten years that
things are going to change very
dramatically and so I I appreciate you
guys letting me give my share my
passions today and I hope that some of
you will will join the discussions right
jump on github web assembly dot slash
design check out some of the things that
people are talking about see what it is
that might be coming in and the problems
and it's also you know a great waste
place to ask some questions you know
they're a very friendly crew people ask
dumb questions all the time and that's
totally cool like it's it's totally cool
although all the guys are very very kind
and understanding so I you know when I
first got it started I asked so I asked
several really really dumb questions
that in hinds
I'm embarrassed but but you know and as
I got up to speed it just keeps exciting
me more and more so I if you have
questions feel free to find me
afterwards or tonight and I thank you
very much for your time
[Applause]